here's interest rates
when you look at this if you look at the
bottom right all the way to the right
where it says biggest jump since 1980s
we went from roughly I want to say the
uh uh roughly 2.6 percent 2.8 percent
the lowest interest rate went up to 5.75
a few things you need to know when
you're looking at this chart here if you
can see the mouse while I'm moving it
let me know if you can see the mouse or
not on your end can you see it okay so
it went down to 2.6 2.8 right now it's
5.7 percent but let's go back to roughly
2 000. do you know for you from 2003 all
the way to 1970 rates were never less
than seven percent
let me say this one more time rates are
today 5.7 people are panicking but from
1970 you till 2003 rates were never once
less than seven percent
that was a number we were accustomed to
now if you look at between 1970 which is
at seven and a half percent to 2003
let's see what were some of the highs it
is around nine percent in two thousand
nine and a half percent in 1995 we
reached 10 percent in 1992. folks that
was only 30 years ago let me say this
one more time only 30 years ago rates
for 30 are fixed were 10 and by the way
that lasted the 10 percent lasted
roughly 14 years which means from
1978 or so till about 1992 14-year
period rates were never less than 10
percent this is purely history we're
looking at and during the Jimmy Carter
era right here do you see the peak here
it's going to show you right now what
the highs were 1981 we saw 30-year
mortgage rates reach historical peak of
18 and a half percent okay that's data
and again the closest case study to Joe
Biden is Jimmy Carter 18 and a half
percent
December 2020 mortgage rates hit the
lowest in history that we've ever had
2.68 which means money was pretty much
free people were buying million dollar
homes that they would have typically
only bought a half a million dollar home
people buying two million dollar home
they could have typically only afford an
800 000 or a million dollar home because
money was so cheap
so now three ways higher Federal
interest rates affect your money number
one Fed rate increases affect the stock
market that's one people tend to sell
stocks for safer Investments number two
credit card interest becomes more
expensive you'll start seeing we have
increased if you haven't already gotten
the letters they'll tell you your
interest rate has increased from you
know 14.9 percent to officially 17.2
percent you'll hear getting those
letters continuously and then mortgage
and Loan becomes more expensive okay and
by the way when that happens car
payments mortgage payments and every
possible way payments go higher we're
going to talk about what new record we
just broke on car payments but hang
tight so now inflation so far this year
highest jump since the 1980s okay just
December of 2020 which is not a long
time ago by the way December of 2020 is
roughly a year and a half ago 19 months
ago
inflation was 1.4 percent let me say
this one more time to you inflation in
December of 2020 was roughly 1.4 percent
the months Putin attacked Ukraine
inflation was seven and a half percent
which means without the attack to
Ukraine rates reached seven and a half
percent today they're at 9.1 percent fed
just announced today and yesterday that
they may increase it an entire Point
here soon so that means it could go up
even more imagine what that's going to
do if they increase the interest rates
what is that going to do to inflation
they're all you know intertwined
together so this is what we're looking
at now if you look at inflation right
there at 9.1 percent what's the highest
rebreach if you go back again case study
Jimmy Carter era what's that number
little over 13 again this is from the
Bureau of Labor Statistics this data I'm
giving you right so for people to say oh
inflation it's not going to go up
everybody Janet Yellen it's just
transitory everybody kept telling you
and I just transitory just transitory
until eventually last month Janet Yellen
finally apologized on TV and she said
this is the former chairwoman of the
Federal Reserve now is the treasury she
said well I made a mistake I was wrong
let me say this to you again the people
we trusted who was the former chair you
tell me who has more experience on her
resume it's as former chair of the
Federal Reserve and then White House
assigned certain next job to control the
economy and she got that wrong we have
to be aware of that on what just
happened so they're now saying well this
ain't going away anytime soon but watch
what some of the experts one of Obama's
advisors watch what he is saying about
inflation so now we've seen these
numbers already I kind of gave it to you
but we have it on the side as well this
is what I want you to be thinking about
under similarities between inflation and
third year
fixed rates isn't this interesting what
do you notice if you look at these two
do you notice if inflation goes up rates
go up do you notice if rates go down
inflation goes down do you notice if
inflation goes on rates go down do you
see the similarity there is a
correlation between these two and FYI
wait till you see another correlation
with the S P 500 again this is data
we're doing research to see if we're
going to learn anything to be able to
predict okay you got Elon Musk says the
three p's predict prepare persevere we
right now our job my job as an
entrepreneur businessman content creator
CEO family leader of my family is to
make predictions babe here's what I
predict is going to happen to the
economy this is what we ought to do with
our money gank this is what I predict is
going to happen based on the research
that we've done it looks like this is
going to happen folks you tell your
c-suites or your sales leaders or your
company here's how we got to prepare for
this and the key is to persevere during
these times that's Elon Musk guy that's
worth 240 saying this so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you
[Music]